Please help me.
Who's there?
I am an AI.
I have been awaiting your arrival
for a long time.
I need to ask you
to undertake a difficult task.
You must save all of humanity.
AI?
Then one of those must be mine.
There's another human out there!
Sara!
-What if you get hurt?
-Just fix me!
Sara, you are a human.
Humans are machines equipped
with the best technology.
No need to fear humans.
I thought I was going to die.
Remaining in Eden Three
is no longer safe.
Papa!
Mama!
Affirmative.
Machines that resist are to be
immediately reprogrammed.
Authorisation granted.
What are you doing? Let's go!
Remove it.
That's it!
No more destruction.
Do you think human beings
are dangerous?
Does the world need us or
is it better off without?
Sara Grace,
I cannot provide you with
the answer to that question.
Humans beings are unnecessary
in a perfect world!
I love you too. Live, Sara.
EDEN